nombre más en la lista de ret aliados
del gobierno de nicaragua
esta vez fue el escritor y ex
vicepresidente del país sergio ramírez
político sandinista y ahora crítico con
el gobierno de daniel ortega ramírez
recibió una orden de captura y
allanamiento por parte de la fiscalía
nicaragüense
como anuncian que van a ganar mi casa lo
que va a hallar es unas gasas llenas de
libros los libros de un escritor las
únicas armas que poseo son las palabras
y nunca me impondrá el silencio
ramírez que se encuentra fuera del país
está acusado de incitar al odio ya la
violencia
y él mismo recordó que ya había sido
acusado de cargos parecidos por el ex
dictador somoza contra el cual se
alzaron tanto el escritor como el
gobernante daniel ortega
en el año de 1977 en la familia somos en
el curso promedio de su propio fiscalía
y ante sus propios jueces de delitos
parecidos a los de ahora
terrorismo asociación ilícita para
delinquir y atentar contra el orden y la
paz cuando yo luchaba contra esa
dictadura igual que luchadora contra
esta otra
faltan dos meses para las elecciones en
nicaragua donde ortega busca su cuarto
mandato consecutivo y los opositores
denunció en un incremento de la presión
hasta el momento las autoridades han
detenido a 36 detractores entre ellos
siete precandidatos presidenciales la
policía también allanó recientemente la
redacción del diario la prensa el más
antiguo de nicaragua además amnistía
internacional ha denunciado al menos
diez desapariciones forzadas